it's not often that I think of an
experiment for periodic videos where I
really want to know the answer rather
than just having a regular demonstration
today I thought of one those experiments
there is quite a well-known effect known
as a fuel coolant interaction where a
molten metal drops a into water and
causes an explosion and we've sort of
had some of those in some of our videos
with caesium and sodium in water but
there you have a metal which gets hot
through a chemical reaction I was
suddenly thought why don't we try
dropping mercury into liquid nitrogen
because mercury is hot it's room
temperature liquid nitrogen is at minus
196 degrees centigrade their hypothesis
is that because the metal conducts heat
so well the heat will come out very
quickly and there be a whoosh as all the
light children vaporizes the experiment
was done in three stages so first of all
liquid nitrogen with solid copper same
temperature as the mercury but because
it's solid there's no change in surface
area can't break up into small droplets
so it should be safer so he put it in
and much to our pleasure it really
looked quite nice
so that part at least was safe but just
to be doubly sure he then dropped the
mercury the first time into really big
vessel so that even if there was
splashing and so on none would come out
the thing that particularly pleased me
was that when the mercury froze because
the freezing point to mercury is minus
40 degrees centigrade there were quite
nice crystals that you could see formed
and the surface of the metal and there
was this great lump of mercury at the
bottom solid but Neel had quite lots of
difficulty getting it out at the end and
it began to melt and so on but that
wasn't part of the experiment
then came the real experiment a small
vacuum flask where you can see inside
without condensation on the surface from
the vapor pressure in the air and he
dropped in the mercury what's
interesting is that as it goes into the
liquid nitrogen the nitrogen boils and
so the mote crew Falls almost encased in
the sort of bubble of nitrogen gas then
when it gets the bottom it goes splat on
the bottom spreads out and then the
transfer of heat becomes much more
violent and there is a huge upwelling
mercury going this way and bubbles of
gas going up as an experiment it was
really nice it looked really good I'm
not completely convinced that it
demonstrates how well heat is
transferred from a liquid but you can
see that it's far more violent than when
you drop in a lump of copper because the
surface area of the mercury is much much
larger and the heat travels out through
the surface through the interface
between the liquid nitrogen and the
metal so I think in the end we have
demonstrated the point that even with a
difference of just over 200 degrees
centigrade you can get quite a violent
boiling imagine now if you put in really
hot mercury if you put in boiling
mercury into liquid nitrogen then you
might get really quite a bang
you might even break the vessel well I'd
be happy for you to do it Neal would not
be
P we would smash his vessel and he'd
have to clear up the mess as well